the most teams that could be 2-0 in a
32-team league are 16
11 this year have reached that milestone
the most ever tied with three other
seasons when the nfl had 11 2-0 teams so
what we're going to do in the second
hour of this wednesday edition of pfc
live we're going to go through the 11
2-0 teams and we're going to give them a
label contender pretender there's still
a long way to go there have been teams
that have racked up very good records at
the beginning and they have
ultimately fallen apart so christopher
we uh
we are going to embark on that process
as we
embark on this hour of pft live and
let's get right to it okay um scale of
one to ten is what we're going to use to
determine pretender or contender so
there's some wiggle room it's not pass
failed yeah there's some curve to this
let's start with the favorites in the
afc let's begin with the team that's at
the top of the mountain the
kansas city chiefs they've beaten the
houston texans at home they they got
pushed to the brink against the la
chargers in week two where do you put
them pretender to contenders scale of
one to ten i'm i mean the chiefs the
ravens they're tens for me i mean i i
don't i don't need to see i know they
start with the chiefs okay just achieve
something
a little bit but the chiefs yes i mean
10 10 on the scale contender i mean was
last week the way i want it to look if
you're a chiefs fan or you know you know
a fan of high execution on the offensive
side of the ball and stuff like that no
the chiefs were were not at their best
and the chargers defense let's not
forget it's really damn good um but
i'm still completely confident in this
football team there's no doubt and uh i
like your power rankings i i think
they're either the one or two best teams
in football
last week is the game that any team but
the chiefs loses
that's the the greatness of the chief
agreed that they were able to come back
and win that game right when it looked
like a lost cause for most of the day
plenty of other teams just accept it at
some point you accept it and and that's
the beauty of patrick mahomes they've
been in that position so many damn times
they thrive on it they want to show you
once again that they can dig out of that
hole and i think that it's having a
psychological impact on the opponent now
because they're all starting to think
here we go again yeah and the chiefs are
ultimately going to take care of us so
yeah i think there are 10 uh without
question and i think it is going to come
down to them and the team they play on
monday night the next team on the list
the baltimore ravens they have beaten
the cleveland browns convincingly
they've beaten the texans convincingly
and i'm convinced they're a 10 as well
although to the extent like there's got
to be some separate does there have to
be separation i don't think there does
half right i don't know nine and a half
for the ravens nine and a half okay i i
i i feel like it's every bit right up
the par with the chiefs though i mean i
feel like it's right up there in fact
you know if i was really going to get
picky that way i'd maybe go with chiefs
9.8 and then to give the ravens the 10.0
right now just after two weeks but
the the ravens as we've discussed many
times there's just not a weakness to
their football team on paper on roster
let alone
you know they're very creative
schematically and then they have some
big time play makers i mean that that's
just the big thing
okay oh lamar hey you know the running
game this week and then it's you know
it's marcus peters making a pick this
week last week it was class campbell
getting them jump started you know it's
just we talk about some teams where we
go who's going to make that play to get
them going we know we had that
conversation about the saints and the
right right like the ravens you don't
ever have a question about the ravens or
the chiefs we know they got somebody on
both sides of the ball where you go big
moment guarantee one of those big
players show up
yeah i agree with you and you know what
i'll make the ravens a 10. if the scale
is
one is a definite pretender and two is a
definite contender they are both
definite contenders through two weeks
and they will continue to be contenders
regardless of what happens on monday
night win or lose key players have to
stay healthy though i mean that's the
key lamar jackson or patrick mahomes go
down right and that changes everything i
don't want to jinx anyone by saying that
but but
but we need to have your quarterback
obviously or you know there aren't many
teams out there where you're going to
say take out the starting quarterback
and everything is going to be fine
afc dark horses so far the
las vegas raiders at 2-0 and the
steelers at 2-0 i expected the steelers
to be 2-0 i didn't expect the game
against the giants to be as close as it
was the 10-point margin of victory did
not reveal how close it really was and
then with the broncos it was a
five-point victory the raiders pulling
off that win against the saints on
monday night makes me wonder about them
let's start with them where would you
put the raiders on that scale of one to
ten pretender to contender i'm more i
feel in the i'm gonna say a five right
now really right right around that area
there's there's there's still two
really one big question is the defense
i think that still worries me and then
you know that goes into the conversation
getting young
uh it's not like a scheme that i look at
and go oh wow it's so awesome and
creative and then two yeah there's just
not difference makers on that side of
the ball for them either so yeah i worry
about that aspect and and just like we
saw a little again on monday night derek
carr was awesome but we know there was a
few plays early on where you go oh there
was more there to be had you know you
got a strike there
again they've been fined through two
weeks on the offensive side of the ball
but i just feel like there's going to be
that week where teams are going to take
away the quick throws to the back and
the quick throws to waller and you're
going to have to go downfield and i just
haven't seen that yet either let alone
my concerns with the defense that's why
i'm going to go five
and again we don't know how good or bad
any of these opponents really will end
up being and with the saints the jury's
out now yeah where they are how much of
what happened monday night was the
saints how much of it was the raiders i
agree with you the raiders are firmly
out of five and it's gonna break one way
or the other based upon what they do
going forward and raiders fans if you
want your team to get the respect that
you are insisting upon in the aftermath
of the win over the saints
go to new england this weekend and beat
the patriots and the respect definitely
will come with the pittsburgh steelers
they were viewed as a serious contender
going into the season they were viewed
as one of the biggest threats to the
ravens in the afc north where do you
have them based upon what you've seen
through two weeks on that scale of one
to ten i'm like
seven or eight ish uh i guess i guess
really i probably feel i i feel like i'm
seeing seven-ish but i'm gonna say eight
because it's the steelers and the part
that i'm worried about is just like okay
big ben's not at his best yet that
offense isn't clicking all the way they
had a few stale moments in the giants
game had a few stale moments last week
against the denver broncos
so yeah from what i've seen i want to
say it's a seven but i have faith in and
people like big ben and pittsburgh that
they'll get this together and the young
receivers and it's just it's new year
and big ben didn't play in a year
so i guess i look at it like that and
then i guess the defense
has been again that you know
a little underwhelming it's still
awesome
but
i guess there was chances i would would
have expected the steelers to just slam
the door last week against the denver
broncos and they let them kind of hang
around so i'm gonna go eight
because it's the steelers
and i i think the defense is still legit
and i just think big ben's gonna get
continue to get better and better
i'm gonna stay seven because i don't
think either win this year has been the
kind of win we thought we were gonna get
from the steelers wins or wins it's
money in the bank they have the
opportunity to improve as every team
does they're going to need to improve
the defense is awesome the offense is a
work in progress right now seven it can
skew
eight nine ten but it also can go the
other way if the offense doesn't uh
doesn't get better quickly between the
two raiders and steelers which one's a
bigger threat to topple the chiefs or
the ravens respect so me the steelers
that steelers i they have the type of
talent and scheme to where like i
wouldn't be shocked if they were one of
the first teams that like stymie the
baltimore ravens offense and something
like that and and even in a game like if
they couldn't stymie the chiefs or
something like that i think we're
starting to see i worry about the
running game but i think we're we're
still you know with claypool a big play
last week deontay johnson showed up
again you're starting to see like all
right they might have some talent at
receiver you know in a few weeks time we
might be able to say like what
pittsburgh if they got in the shootout
with kansas city they'll be okay i feel
like it's going to trend that way but
i'm like you i just i don't know yet i'd
like to see a little bit more
from the department of obscure facts
chase claypool's 84 yard touchdown catch
and run on sunday the longest touchdown
play
for a canadian-born
player wow in nfl history yeah so he's
having that going for him which is nice
afc south titan's the only 2-0 team
they've beaten the broncos they beat the
jaguars both games were razor thin
margins two points over the broncos
three points over the jaguars
where do you put the titans on this
scale i know you know the titans are one
of those teams yeah they're 2-0 they
were in the afc championship game last
year i know they're in the top 10 of
your power rankings but i don't know how
to feel about them for through two weeks
i don't
i like the way they look on the field
but i don't necessarily like the way
they're performing on the field you know
so i'm i'm gonna say like a six right
now you know they could easily be o and
two there's no doubt about it i mean
they could be owen two so that's where
it's hard to just sit there and go oh
i'm gonna give them an eight nine or ten
no
um
you know the the defense still lets up
way too many big plays i mean for
jacksonville to move the ball the way
they did denver was so close to making a
ton of big plays jerry judy dropped a
bunch of big passes in that game so
uh that's where i worry about them a
little bit right now is i just uh
yeah i'm not sure about that defense and
who's going to be the guy that can shut
things down or what unit is special for
that defense right now
elite teams don't just barely beat bad
teams they beat the crap out of bad
teams that's what gives me concern yes
and it could just be that the titans are
going to play up and down to the level
of the competition you know will they
screw around with the vikings this
weekend instead of stick it to them the
way that they're capable of doing and
then there's that battle coming with the
steelers that maybe that's when they
rise up but for a team that notoriously
starts slowly to get two wins out of the
gates is good news yeah that's right
because they've lost too many of these
early season games in recent years but
they are really the quietest of the 2-0
teams and this fits the profile at some
point in the past few years the titans
became a team that is largely irrelevant
and even getting to the afc championship
game last year didn't change that vibe
and they still look good and to me did
you did you pick a number for them i i
put them i put them at yeah i put them
at seven as well
uh because
look they should have beaten the broncos
by a lot more than a couple of points
missed field goals doomed them there
i've yet they'll go back and re-watch
the jaguars titans game i'm i'm going to
do that today yeah the concerning thing
was how that one feels right right i
know i don't have a great feel of it
either i need to go back and watch it
too
but just the fact you know two long
drives at the end of the game i mean
jaguars hadn't had like the ball where
we need to score a touchdown and they
went down the field bing bang boom seven
eight nine play drives two two or three
times there where you just went
damn like that was easy minchu looked
like he was just carving them up and i
think that's what scares me a little bit
about tennessee
all right the buffalo bills at 2-0 in
the afc east with a one-game lead over
the new england patriots they'll see the
patriots twice eventually for now
they've got the rams coming up who also
are two-and-oh where do you put the
bills on the one-to-ten list i'm giving
them a niner i'm giving them a niner
captain i'm saying that's right i'm
stunned by that well
i'll say this the only reason they're
not getting a tenor okay is because
i i
josh allen
that's the reason he now they're at nine
because of josh allen but the reason
they're not at ten is because of josh
allen
yeah i mean we still we see a little
splash here and there of crazy josh
allen last week i mean he runs over
uh uh a safety and then he runs over a
d-lineman i mean runs them over like
you're like what am i watching walter
payton or a quarterback here
and then he's still fighting and fumbles
the ball now luckily they recovered but
you just go damn josh allen just go down
it wasn't worth it but yet the plays he
makes are astounding and he's one of the
best playmakers in the game right now
and their offense is dangerous as hell
they can run the ball they trust him
and then diggs beasley john brown
mckenzie i mean they got speed a
receiver to where it's going to be tough
for anybody to match up with them the
kid they got a tight end dawson knox he
had two big drops last week one was a
fumble he's a hell of a player so yeah
and then we know their defense is good
that's why i go nine i i mean the only
reason they're not 10 is just that
little trust tree factor with josh allen
the josh allen performance for the first
two weeks of the season it put him in a
category and this is an obscure
statistical thing but patrick mahomes
tom brady and peyton manning are the
only others to have more than 700
passing yards six or more touchdowns and
no interceptions in the first two games
of a season so that is pretty good
company to be in mahomes brady and
manning josh allen has been playing
really well i made the observation
earlier this week that the bills have
been looking for jim kelly and for
thurman thomas and they found both guys
in the same person
he needs to at some point
hit the deck i the the way he gets
banged around and i understand and this
is the difference between him and kyler
murray kyler murray is obsessed with the
reality that you need to live another
play josh allen gets overcome by
competitiveness yes and at some point
that's going to get him in trouble it's
the carson wentz mentality no doubt and
it's fine until it's not fun right
that's right it is it's the scariest
thing and you know that's my boy blue
and i just yes get the hell down you
know and and that's the you know that's
the problem he's been a big physical
beast his whole life so high school run
people over
college
hey college they were so bad i mean it
was almost you know a bad thing for him
that they were that bad because they
basically just were like go do whatever
you got to do we stink so you have the
free reign to throw the ball into
quadruple coverage and run around like a
chicken without his head cut off or with
his head cut off and do whatever and
that really set him back as far as being
an nfl quarterback but like his school
had no choice he was so far the best
player that they had to let him just be
raw and go and it kind of hurt his
development there but hopefully he can
reign in it we're seeing them raining in
and just about everything and even in
that area it's been rained in it's just
still not where you and i would like it
to be
you know i've got a theory and i don't
know it's more of a hypothesis guys like
carson wentz who played at north dakota
state josh allen at wyoming i feel like
they have an extra chip on their
shoulder to prove they belong so they're
more willing to go out there yeah and
embrace those hits to show these guys
from the sec schools and the big ten
schools right that that they're every
bit as good and tough and strong and and
willing to go out there and play hard as
they are i you know in that complicated
stew of human emotions and motivations i
can't help but wonder whether that's in
there somewhere i don't think it's crazy
thought mike i do i think those guys
probably are you know like got a
permanent chip on their shoulder they're
going like how the hell did i end up at
that school and did not ohio state or
notre dame or anybody want me i mean
so yeah they're probably permanently
pissed off by that stuff
are are you calling the bills at this
point definitely the division favorite
are the jury still out because the
patriots are better than you thought
yeah the patriots are better than they
thought they would be so i'm not going
to say it i'm giving them the edge and i
you know yeah i i probably would have
put the bills ahead of the the patriots
by one rank in your power rankings if i
had a say or anything like that but it's
very close and uh yeah i've liked what
i've seen with the patriots
how would their defense hold up against
cam newton during their inevitable two
games against him yeah that would be
interesting i mean mcdermott is again
one of those guys where
you
he just he'll go outside the book or
outside the normal realm of thought to
where he's gonna bring a few creative
angles to a defensive approach to stop
some of those tricks and do things like
that did a pretty good job last year
containing lamar jackson and the
baltimore ravens when they came to town
really lamar made some big throws that
ended up winning that game for them and
things like that so
uh that would be the ultimate chess
match and they match up good with that
new england offense and i don't know how
that'll play out
week eight the day after halloween and
then week 16 three days after christmas
those are the two times the bills and
the patriots might be for the division
after christmas this year exactly let's
go to the nfc
north because there are no unbeaten
teams in the nfc east the green bay
packers
i one to ten you're going to give them
an 11 i assume no i'm not i'm not going
to give them 11.
i'm going to give them a 9. i'm going to
give them a 9. but
actually i don't know why i'm giving
them a nine actually as i'm sitting here
you're right i'm going to give them a
10. i am
you know though the one if we keep
talking it may go down i might go to 11.
well hey you know that old saying if
you're staying the same you're getting
worse
well green bay's just crapped on that
theory i mean they crapped all over it
they said oh no we stayed the same and
we got better we they're better i don't
know any other way to say it offense is
better they're doing more in the run
game so there's more wrinkles to that
and then rogers is playing insane i mean
rogers is playing insane i love that he
went 18 for 30 last week you know why he
went 18 for 30 and his completion
percent is not at 75 percent oh my gosh
what are we gonna do because they're
more dangerous when he's 18 to 30.
because when he's thrown in completions
like that that means they're taking
chances down the field and he's letting
go that rocket right arm and that's when
they're at their best so
and their defense other than those first
two drives last week have been very
impressive the whole year so i yeah i'm
going packers 10. i am
there is a chance that they just happen
to catch the two worst teams they're
gonna see all year they're right i don't
know how bad the vikings are gonna be we
don't know where the bottom is i was
looking at the vikings scheduled 0 and 5
is available real possibility
very real possibility for the vikings
and it may come down to the falcons week
6 to avoid going into the bye week 0 and
6. so it is possible that it's been a
little smoke and mirrors and you know
i'm gonna give them a nine
reluctantly because i
they created this vibe they were
consciously taking a step back i mean if
you're that damn close
if you really are that close and if
you're going to be that much better in
the second year of the matlab floor
offense why in the bleep are you not
using that first round pick on an area
of need it is why
do you give up your fourth round pick
which you use to trade up when you
combine it with your first round pick to
get a quarterback that isn't going to
play
if you continue to have faith in aaron
rodgers that makes no sense to me this
is your opportunity to go all in and to
get the guy that's going to help you get
over the top and that's what frustrates
me about this if they knew they were
going to be this good why in the double
bleep did they not take a receiver in
that spot i don't know or you know yeah
or just address it in a free agency a
trade whatever it may be but yeah i had
somebody yesterday say to me well didn't
this kind of prove that the packers knew
what they were doing
and i would go no in fact it's actually
the opposite to me it just shows me like
did they miss evaluate their team and
think they were farther off
and that they just went to hell with
this year you know yeah we're good and
we'll hang in there but we need to build
for three years down the road i mean
because you're right if you think you're
that good and like you know hopefully
lefour's going no you don't understand
our offense is going to get better they
haven't even got into the you know the
advanced part of it yet so all those
things and everything into it
yeah that to me so what we've seen so
far is just go i know it's been good but
how good could it have been if we got
that one extra play or maybe on each
side of the ball just to give a little
more juice
that could be scary and nonetheless it's
been good so far so it's hard to
complain about what they have at
receiver and things like that but they
still got drops and and things like that
too where you just go it's not clean but
it's a lot better than what we've seen
the last few years
they got the crap kicked out of them
twice last year by the 49ers they
freaked out they thought they had to
retreat to the laboratory and come up
with some different approach if they
were ever going to contend with the
49ers and here are the 49ers falling
apart and it's the last team the packers
currently have to worry about they
should be worried about the bears the
bears are 2-0 in unlikely fashion i have
a feeling this is gonna be the lowest of
the one to ten scores that you give out
today what do you have well
i i feel like yeah i don't know they're
kind of in that raiders territory but
like vice versa to me where i'm gonna go
a six with the bears i'll give them yeah
i'm gonna give them a six i think just
because i still have faith in that
defense i do
i think that defense is still gonna keep
them in a lot of football games to where
the offense as we saw last year they
were eight and eight with one of the
worst offenses in football i mean it's
stunk
if they just have a middle of the road
offense
you know i just think they're one of
those teams that yeah they're gonna be
dancing around that nine and seven maybe
ten and six
type record this year so right now yeah
maybe i'm a little more bullish on the
bears uh but i'm gonna go six i am
yeah i i look we're doing a bad job
of grading on a curve here uh nobody's
been below five the bears have to be
below five i'm i'm gonna say four okay
for the bears which they probably should
be one if there's going to be a ten
there's gotta be they can't maybe they
all could be contenders i don't know but
the bears are a four for me they still
have to prove that they they can do it
consistently and not pull the rabbit out
of the hat like they did against the
lions barely hold on against the giants
it came down to one play one shot at the
goal line i want to see something a
little more compelling and a little more
sustained and consistent yeah before i
buy into the bears especially since they
still have to play the packers twice
maybe nfc west high on them go you want
to change it i'll give you a chance okay
i'll go five i think five is probably
where i want to be i don't want to go to
four area but i like five okay the nfc
west has three of the two and oh teams
the seahawks the rams and the cardinals
with the 49ers in the basement at one
and one let's start with the seahawks
one to ten what do you got well that's a
ten i mean we know that i mean they're
they're i mean we're talking about
contenders and yeah what who's more of a
contender packers or seahawks
whoo man um
i guess i'm gonna go seahawks right now
but it is by a slim slim margin i mean
slim
it really is uh but but the the seahawks
i just think with what way russell
wilson's playing
pete carroll
jamal adams and what he does to the
defense i mean jamal adams quandary
diggs and quentin dunbar
really changed their defense and those
were big time moves made by pete carroll
and john schneider i got to give them
credit it really has it's allowed them
to do more things on the defensive side
of the ball which excites me too not
that i think it's going to be a top five
defense but i think it's going to be a
top five pain in your butt top five we
can make plays and cause chaos every
week type defense where they might give
up yards and big plays but that's fine
because we want to let russ cook just
like we talked about with kansas city
last year you don't want to be doing
slow death defense in seattle get your
guy back out there let him start
throwing the ball either you cause a
turnover or you get the you let up a big
play and you get russell back out and
get the offense going because that's the
best part of your football team
5-0 the buy is very possible for the
seattle seahawks cowboys at the dolphins
home game against the vikings that's a
sunday night game
and then oh that's gonna be an ugly
sunday night game can we flex out of a
week five sunday night game and then
after their bye week it's a showdown
with the arizona cardinals they both
will be undefeated going into that game
so favorable schedule coming up in
seattle and i put them firmly at a 10. i
think they're right now they're in my
mind the super bowl favorite in the nfc
and you pick them to win the super bowl
before the season so you have to think
they're the best contender in the nfc i
do i didn't pick him to win i think i
had him losing to the chiefs in the in
the super bowl but yeah that's right
yeah i picked the chief's job i can't go
against the homes and all that but i
mean yeah and you know i mean your
freaking vikings messing up our sunday
night football schedule i mean geez
unbelievable
this will be the year that they go out
there and win no it'll be a year when
they go out there this will be a great
it'd still be a great game it's still
russell wilson in prime time doesn't
matter who they're playing right they
could play a high school team and
russell wilson in prime time is worth
the price of administration and the
fight for the vikings i'm not ready to
look the vikings have always gone out
there and had to deal with that crowd
going out there and not having to deal
with that crowd could change things
that's the fly in the ointment because
it seems like the vikings get a short
straw to play there in prime time every
year this is the year to play the
seahawks in prime time at home so you
keep telling me keep telling yourself
i'm going to hold on to a shred of hope
i think it's going to be a better game
than you think maybe i'll even pick the
vikings to win the game that night on
football night in america all right the
la rams one to ten what do you got well
uh i
i i s huh
i guess i'm gonna say
i'm gonna go
eight ish i wanna go eight i'm gonna go
eight i am
i just think between mcveigh the
offensive line being better
uh and their ability to run the football
goff has looked really good and not that
he's asked to do a whole lot but of
course he runs that offense at a pace
and gets them in and out of the right
place and then when he's had to make
some big throws in the last two weeks
he's made them so the offense has been
really encouraging the defense it
doesn't like blow your doors off but
they got a few playmakers and they don't
mess up that is the one thing i've
noticed for two weeks they're not doing
a lot of creative stuff things like that
on the defensive side of the ball but
they mix it up and they're sound and
there's something to that i and they're
a battle tested proven winning type
football team so yeah i mean i guess
seven or eight right there in that attic
category 7.5 if i had to give the rams
but i think they are going to be a
playoff team as you know as i pick them
before the year
i'm more than willing to admit that i'm
wrong in part because i'm so used to
doing it the rams are much better than i
thought they were going to be i'll put
them at an eight and i think they're
going to get better and better as they
get more and more comfortable with this
new group of coaches personnel etc as
they continue to move forward all right
the arizona cardinals
scale of one to ten
where do you put that i'm at a six i
think with them
i i i still
am not a like a believer in their
defense at this point
you know the washington the washington
uh offense is certainly nothing i'm
gonna sit there and go well they stopped
washington they're they're proven
you know san francisco made a lot of big
plays really screwed that game up in a
lot of ways so
uh i just don't know what to know what
their defense their offense we know what
it is
i mean it's kyla murray it's shotgun
it's stress you out that way quick
throws him moving and then the
occasional deep throw down the field and
everything like that
um but i don't know i guess i'm just not
quite sure about how good they are yet i
mean i think they're going to be a pain
in the butt of uh but fly in the
ointment always around the playoff
conversation am i willing to sit here
right now and just go oh
you know they're definitely in the
playoffs no no by no stretch of the
imagination yet i'd like to evaluate
them a little longer
yeah look in any other division i would
give them a seven or an eight i agree
with you they were a six in part because
they have to deal with the seahawks
twice and the rams twice and they have
to play the 49ers again and i am holding
out hope for the possibility of all four
teams from the nfc west making it to the
playoffs this year just because i always
like a little chaos a little healthy
chaos that's a little healthy chaos they
add a playoff team and so all the wild
cards come from the same division and
the fact that they play all the teams of
the nfc east and the afc east makes it a
little bit easier this year for the
teams of the nfc west to pull it off who
stays undefeated the longest out of
those three seahawks rams and cardinals
um ooh i wish i was seahawks rams and
cardinals it's hard for me not to i i'd
like to pull up the schedules and really
go through it there but it's hard for me
not to pick the seahawks right now i
mean just the way they're playing and
the playmakers they got and russell
wilson's confidence and his arm right
now and what he's seeing on the field
yeah just my first thought would be the
seahawks
and the rams have to go play your boy
blue this weekend in buffalo i haven't
seen i assume the rams went home
philadelphia back to la back to buffalo
the opposite of what the 49ers have done
hunkering down here in west virginia for
the week but that's a lot of air miles
that's a lot of travel time for the rams
home from philly and back to buffalo if
that's what they're indeed what would
you rather get harder for them yeah i
mean i'd rather i'd you'd rather stay
i talked to kyle about it last year yeah
after
after the
tampa cincinnati
it was right after the cincinnati game
right he said that they've done it both
ways and that on that second game
the morning of that second game
especially because it's usually a 10
o'clock local time game pacific time
right the guys are just dead no matter
what they do they are dead they were
bouncing off the walls the day that they
were getting ready to play the bengals
because think about it they've been away
from home all week they're excited to go
home there's an extra little energy and
they beat them and they're used to the
time
yeah it works it works and last year
they did it twice
and they won the back end both times
they beat the saints on the back end of
staying away from home for a week and
they beat the bengals on the back end
earlier in the year so i think it makes
sense i think the rams may find out the
hard women they go play the bills that
they wish they had stuck around new york
somewhere for the week instead of going
back and forth and back and forth
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports